[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes le jeudi 16
novembre lors du 7-8 journal sur tv 78
les titres de cette édition
ils sont accusés d'avoir séquestré leur
chef d'equipe neuf salariés du site psa
à poissy comparaissait aujourd'hui
devant le tribunal de grande instance de
versailles est un rassemblement de
soutien se tenait devant le tgi en
présence de plusieurs figures politiques
de la gauche
nous étions sur place lundi c'est la
journée mondiale des droits de l'enfant
l'occasion de célébrer l'adoption de la
convention internationale le 20 novembre
1989 à l'onu à 28 ans plus tard ce texte
est il bien appliquée éléments de
réponse avec philippe journée quand
délégué de l'unicef 78 et puis retour
sur la soirée d'ouverture du festival
saint quentin au programme hier au à
l'ugc skywest le compositeur vladimir
cosma était l'invité d'honneur de la
cérémonie
l événement dédié au film documentaire
se déroule jusqu'à dimanche à saint
quentin en yvelines thème cette année la
musique c'était une promesse de campagne
d'emmanuel macron la mise en place de la
police de sécurité du quotidien les
premières expérimentations doivent
débuter de billes 2018 et ce matin à
versailles le préfet et des yvelines
serge morvan a lancé une large
concertation sur le sujet en présence
d'élus des autorités d'associations et
de bailleurs sociaux notamment
objectif recueillir les différents avis
les besoins et mettre en avant allers
retours d'expérience sur le terrain et
via des réunions de proximité qui se
dérouleront pendant un mois
propos recueillis par nicolas landry la
police de sécurité du quotidien mais
évidemment il faut qu'elle le soit
déconcentré aussi il faut que son action
soit la plus proche possible du
quotidien et le quotidien c'est pas le
même suivant où vous habitez y compris
dans les yvelines suivant
votre travail suivant votre
votre comment pourrais dire votre
situation familiale ce que vous avez des
enfants vous amener à l'école ou pas
vraiment il ya tout ce qui fait la vie
évidemment du quotidien doit donner lieu
à une en matière de sécurité une réponse
adaptée est la police de sécurité du
quotidien qui est l'objet du prochain
7,8 débat à suivre ce soir sur tv 78
vanessa meflah reçoit julien le cam du
syndicat alliance
et le député des yvelines didier
baichère et des militants de la cgt
devant la justice aujourd'hui à
versailles 9 salariés et de l' usine psa
à poissy comparaissait en début d'après
midi au tribunal de grande instance
ils sont accusés de séquestration par un
chef d'equipe pour les soutenir environ
250 personnes syndicats et politiques
s'étaient réunis en fin de matinée
devant le tribunal sur place marie
pannetrat nicolas kirillovitch et des
yvelines de valenciennes et même des
salariés de renault 300 personnes
étaient présentes à versailles en
soutien aux neuf salariés de l'usiné psa
poissy accusé par leur direction de
séquestration pour des faits remontant
au mois de février
des accusations que les syndicats cgt en
tête rejette en bloc
pour eux ce combat judiciaire est une
simple tentative d'intimidation
vous savez c'est nouveau pour nous des
traités comme des délinquants comme des
voyous de se faire assigner en
correctionnelle alors qu'on n'a rien
fait c'est nouveau maintenant ça ça nous
fait pas peur ça nous impressionne pas
on va pas se démoraliser pour ça au
contraire ça nous renforce
ça veut dire qu'on est des gêneurs on
est des gêneurs dans la politique de
tavares de vouloir exploiter encore plus
les travailleurs le jour même d'une
mobilisation nationale contre la
politique du gouvernement
nombreuses personnalités politiques de
gauche ont aussi participé au
rassemblement
malheureusement cette criminalisation
accrue de l'activité syndicale va de
pair on le voit bien avec l' attaque
contre les droits sociaux et des droits
syndicaux qui sont contenus dans les
ordonnances macro nous sommes toujours
rassemblés
quand il s'agit effectivement de se
battre contre des attaques
à
qu'elle vienne du gouvernement où qu
elles viennent du patronat au moment de
l'enregistrement de ce reportage nous ne
connaissons pas les réquisitions du
procureur de la république
selon la loi les salariés encourt
jusqu'à cinq ans de prison ferme
autre mobilisation cette fois ci à
guyancourt les salariés de sodexo à
dreux mène des actions depuis plusieurs
semaines devant le siège du groupe de
restauration collective et de
multiservices motif la fermeture du site
euréliens annoncé en septembre le plan
social proposé par la direction ne
convient pas une poignée d'employés a
donc décidé de muscler le mouvement
pourtant un accord a été assignée avec
les syndicats reportage marylène
iapichino nicolas dans driss depuis
lundi de salariés du site de production
sodexo à dreux ont entamé une grève de
la faim
la fermeture du site a été annoncée en
septembre pour des raisons
d'adaptabilité aux attentes du marché
les solutions proposées aux salariés
sont jugées indécentes par ces
manifestants un troisième les a rejoint
mardi en soutien
on en est venu à faire une grève de la
faim tout simplement parce qu'on
n'arrive pas à faire entendre la
direction de sodexo que le pse qui nous
ont qu'ils ont mis en place qui a été
signé et validé par les différents
syndicats est complètement en dehors des
attentes des salariés
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on se fait
licencier on compte trois francs six
sous on nous propose des reclassements à
plus de 100 kilomètres de chez nous pour
des salaires minimums et c'est
complètement intolérables
on se bat beaucoup aujourd'hui les
négociations soient réouvertes et que la
direction puisse recevoir les délégués
syndicaux pour qu'il est vraiment des
négociations sérieuses et descentes
le mois dernier une trentaine de
salariés protesté déjà devant le siège
social de l'entreprise à guyancourt
la direction se défend d'avoir négocié
dans les règles avec les partenaires
sociaux
au total le site de production de dreux
comptait 62 salariés dont six ont déjà
été ou sont en voie de reclassement de
ce que devrait proposer dans le cadre de
la négociation entre les partenaires
sociaux a fait l'objet de quatre
réunions de négociation on a pu au
travers des échanges que l'on a fait
prendre en compte leurs attentes
adapter les dispositifs proposés et la
majorité de nos partenaires partenaires
sociaux ont signé cet accord
j'entends effectivement ce que disent
ces personnes qui dans la situation ne
touche que nous prenons en compte qui
nous préoccupe à l'heure actuelle pour
autant la signature de l'ensemble de la
majorité de nos partenaires sociaux
aujourd'hui prévost et c'est bien les
solutions pour chacun des collaborateurs
dans le cadre de cet accord que l'on
soit de pouvoir mettre en oeuvre à
présent l'entreprise de restauration
collective espère une reprise du site et
le maintien d'une vingtaine de postes en
fin de semaine une commission de suivi
aura lieu sur le site de dreux avec les
partenaires sociaux
le texte s'apprête à fêter ses 28 ans le
20 novembre 1989 la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
était adoptée à l'unanimité à l'onu avec
195 pays assignataire c'est l'un des
traités et les plus ratifié de
l'histoire son anniversaire c'est donc
lundi à l'occasion de la journée
internationale des droits de l'enfant
bonsoir philippe journée quand bonsoir
vous êtes le délégué de l'unicef 78
alors ce traité est finalement le socle
de toute l'action de l'unicef la
convention est juridiquement
contraignantes pour les états
signataires qui s'engagent à défendre et
à garantir les droits de tous les
enfants sans digue sans distinction
c'est un texte qui pour la première fois
a reconnu pour les moins de 18 ans a
reconnu les -18 ans comme des êtres à
part entière absolument seul et les
enfants ont des droits
les enfants quel que soit leur âge ont
des droits des droits élémentaires par
exemple le premier droit élémentaire
c'est le droit d'avoir une identité
il ya des pays où il n'y a pas
d'identité un enfant sans identité il
peut être la proie de n'importe qui ne
pas pouvoir se déplacer ou au contraire
être utilisé comme mercenaires
et ça eh bah c'est interdit bien
évidemment par la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
texte donc ratifiant en 1989 c'est à
dire qu auparavant
on ne reconnaissait pas le droit des
enfants officiellement j'avais des idées
des reconnaissances ci mais là c'est ce
texte permet de formaliser un ensemble
de droits il ya quarante et un article
dans dans la convention internationale
des droits de l'enfant
c'est pas quarante et un droit parce
qu'il ya des articles qui permettent
d'affiner certains à certains endroits
mais le droit à l'éducation le droit à
avoir une famille le droit à être nourri
le droit à être vaccinés le droit à ne
pas être malade avoir de l'eau potable
facilement à moins de dix minutes de
chez soi ça rentre dans les principes et
dit c'est le socle de l'unicef non c'est
pas le socle de l'unicef l'unicef a été
fondée en 1946 d'abord pour venir en
aide aux victimes du conflit mondial aux
enfants victimes du conflit mondial et
qu'après le lys elle s'est étendue à
travers le monde ça d'abord été pour
aider les enfants europe et à se
reconstruire
mais avec cette convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
adoptée à l'onu l'unicef qui est une
agence de l'onu se doit de promouvoir
bien évidemment cette convention et
c'est le rôle que nous que nous tenons
très régulièrement tout au long des
années parce qu'il faut toujours
toujours remettre le trait le travail
sur sur la table et 28 ans plus tard où
en est on est ce que cette convention
est bien appliquée on a le sentiment
qu'ils restent quand même des choses à
faire encore il ya bien sûr des choses à
faire
alors je ne parle pas des pays étrangers
et moules à la convention est plus ou
moins bien appliqué plutôt mal dans
certains pays que que bien bien
évidemment déjà ou en france mais en
france en france emma il faut se battre
encore aujourd'hui pour que les
autorités appliquent
concrètement cette cette convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
c'est par exemple c'était le cas par
exemple avec les réfugiés les migrants
de calais les enfants ont les enfants
ont des droits
tous les enfants ont les mêmes droits
qu'ils soient étrangers venus d'ailleurs
ou français donc ses droits n'ont pas
tous été respectée
elle est démantelé il ya un an seulement
qu'il a encore des problèmes bien sûr
qu'il ya toujours des problèmes par
exemple tout enfant a droit à un avocat
on en est bien loin surtout des enfants
qui ne parlent pas français au départ
c'est encore plus compliqué pour eux ils
peuvent être traitées un petit peu
n'importe comment
plutôt bien j'espère mais c'est une une
sauvegarde à mettre en place donc des
choses qui restent à faire alors pour ce
28e anniversaire l'unicef des yvelines
va proposer la semaine prochaine
plusieurs ateliers plusieurs spectacles
avec ce qu'on appelle les villes amies
des enfants dans les yvelines
simplement une raison a ajouté un autre
un autre aspect la convention qui n'est
pas tout à fait respecté le droit à
l'éducation
il y à des milliers d'enfants roms qui
vivent en bidonvilles aujourd'hui qu'il
n'accède pas à l'école
c'est pas normal en france pays des
droits de l'homme
donc il faut il faut se battre il faut
aller voir les autorités compétentes les
responsables politiques pour ma pour
mettre en place réellement un droit de
l'enfant en france la france a ratifié
cette convention en 1990 et est la force
de loi dans l'est dans la loi française
cette convention a force de loi
alors du coup pour le 28e le les 28 ans
de cette convention internationale je le
disais il ya un instant il ya tout un
programme qui se met en place la semaine
prochaine dans les yvelines
alors il ya tout un programme qui se met
en place qui s'est déjà mis en place
parce que bon célébrée le 20 novembre
c'est pas toujours évident à lundi comme
vous l'avez souligné tout à l'heure donc
avec les enfants ça va s'étaler sur
toute la semaine et ça a déjà commencé à
guyancourt par exemple où nous sommes
aujourd'hui pour célébrer cette
convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant mais il ya eu des ateliers sur
travaillant sur cette convention
expliquant les droits aux enfants qui
ont eu lieu hier qui ont été menées par
des bénévoles de l'unicef soixante dix
huit spécialistes de ces plaidoyers qui
sont donc bien mobilisé ses bénévoles de
l'unicef 78
combat actuel la dent les partenaires
pour récolter des dons qu'elles sont si
longs on pense oui forcément à ces
milliers d'enfants ring ya ce qu'ils ont
été contraints à l'exil au bangladesh
les enfants syriens aussi qui subissent
la guerre il ya plusieurs combats
actuels les enfants wingas parlons-en
ils sont à peu près douze mille chaque
jour aujourd'hui à franchir la frontière
entre la birmanie et le bangladesh
c'est assez terrible parce que ces
populations n'ont rien et ils sont
partis ils ont quitté leur province sans
rien et il arrive dans un pays
particulièrement pauvre donc ils sont
vraiment cantonné parquées dans des
camps dans des camps ils ne peuvent
strictement rien faire ils n'ont pas
plus de droits au bangladesh qu'il n'en
avait en birmanie et de plus bon mais il
faut absolument dans un pays en
difficulté qui ne peut pas réellement
mettre en place des structures pour les
accueillir mal l'unicef et où le hcr le
haut comité aux réfugiés des nations
unies doit mettre en place des
structures pour pouvoir accueillir
dignement le plus dignement possible ces
populations pouvoir les nourrir pouvoir
leur apporter un minimum de dos 2-2 et
de matériel pour lutter contre le froid
pour aider ces combats à venir en aide à
ce combat je suis désolé nous reste déjà
une minute les bénévoles de l'unicef
seront présents un peu partout dans les
yvelines en cette fin d'année notamment
sur des marchés noël dans
l'agglomération de 50 ans ni de l'autre
on pourra y acheter les produits de
l'unicef absolument alors
il y a plusieurs sites la campagne de
vente vraiment de ces produits qui nous
permet de récolter les dons nécessaires
pour ces provenir dans pour participer à
ces situations d'urgence mal cette
campagne de vente commence demain au
stand unicef de carrefour montesson ce
donc vendredi et samedi carrefour
montesson carrefour chambourcy le 1er et
le 2 décembre
et puis bon toute une série de marchés
de noël dans les villes amies des
enfants marly montigny elancourt andrésy
conflans sainte honorine
et puis surtout bon mais il ya deux deux
paumes sur lesquels nous sommes là
depuis plusieurs années
c'est le centre commercial de parly 2 où
nous serons du 4 au 26 décembre est
également le stand alone et le stand de
l'unicef au magasin alinéa des
clayes-sous-bois où nous serons du 9 au
26 décembre est vraiment j'espère
récolter un maximum de photos
il faut voir que ces situations
d'urgence demande un financement de 3
mhz de plus de 3 milliards de dollars
l'unicef france participe pour 57
millions à peu près toutes ses dates que
vous avez vous avez parlé on peut les
retrouver bien sûr à sur le site
internet de la délégation locale de
l'unicef qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci philippe journée quand d'avoir été
avec nous délégués l'unicef 78 et je
rappelle un que la délégation recherche
aussi des bénévoles vous pouvez lui
apporter son aide en vous rendant une
nouvelle fois comme je lé précisé sur le
site internet de du comité local merci
merci
hier soir se tenait la soirée
d'ouverture le 3e festival du film
documentaire saint quentin a été lancé
en grande pompe à l'ugc skywest en
présence du compositeur vladimir cosma
thème cette année de l'événement
organisé par tv 60,18 la musique et des
célèbres airs de films ont retenti
durant toute la soirée patrick jacques
de dixmude nicolas kirillovitch elia
rech
[Musique]
si et entonné le célèbre thème musical
de john berry ce n'est pas pour annoncer
l'arrivée de james bond mais plutôt
l'ouverture du festival du film
documentaire saint-quentin spécial
musique
chicken run roméo et juliette sister act
et rabbi jacob
en bon nombre de musiques de films sont
passés entre les mains de l'orchestré
d'harmonie montilly wind orchestra
le célèbre compositeur vladimir cosma
était le grand attendu de la soirée
il a ainsi témoigné de son amour de la
musique mais aussi du cinéma ça me
semble important parce que ça et le
cinéma c'est un art c'est un art l'art
suprême parce que justement il mélange
la littérature le scénario le jeu des
acteurs l'image les décors la musique
tout ça vladimir cosma compositeur de la
musique du film les aventures de rabbi
jacob
en 1973 a même pris plaisir à retrouver
sa baguette le temps d'un morceau il
n'était pas loin de 200 spectateurs et
passionné a participé à la soirée
d'ouverture du festival passionnés
particulièrement de musiques de films et
j'adore quand on les enchaîne comme ça
le plaisir de retrouver les morceaux et
et puis particulièrement le talent de
l'année à venir que ça j'aime bien la
musique de la dmr cosma et comme ma
femme a trouvé justement l'opportunité
de venir ce soir en écoute et bah j'en
ai j'ai profité l'occasion le festival
propose une programmation haute en
musique puisque des classiques comme
chantons sous la pluie une mamma mia
sont diffusés aux côtés des films
documentaires en compétition
la remise des prix a lieu à 16 heures
dimanche 19 novembre au ciné cet élan
pour on vous parlait lui un instant de
la journée internationale des droits de
l'enfant autre événement à partir de
samedi c'est la semaine européenne pour
la réduction des déchets jusqu'au 26
novembre dans le département
l association ressources et vous sera
bien mobilisés pendant l'événement
bonsoir marie fixe bonsoir
elle vous êtes membre du comité de
pilotage de cette ressourcerie
l'association donc ressources et vous
elle a pris place depuis mai dans ses
locaux de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines déjà
une question toute simple pour nos
téléspectateurs c'est c'est quoi une
ressource russe une ressourcerie c'est
un local qui accueille en fait les
objets dont les gens souhaitent se
séparer et qu'il irait naturellement
vers la déchetterie et donc nous nous
récupérons tous ces objets
dans le cas de la prévention des déchets
justement qui notre objectif principal
et nous les préparons s'il y a lieu et
on les remet en vente à tout petit prix
ce qui nous permet de payer les frais de
fonctionnement de notre local et
d'embaucher des personnes notamment
bénéficiaires du rsa parce qu'on a un
partenariat avec conseil départemental
pour embaucher des personnes
bénéficiaires du rsa mais pour
ressources et vous finalement plusieurs
objectifs devaient parler de ces deux
données
cette deuxième vie aux déchets de faire
la prévention de faire de la prévention
mais aussi une idée de lien social
derrière c'est du mans on a donc par le
biais donc de ces emplois qui sont des
emplois aidés pour l'instant en espérant
qu'ils seront pérennisés dans notre
activité
et puis par le biais aussi d'atelier que
nous faisons de sensibilisation pour
accueillir la population environnante
pour les sensibiliser justement à la
prévention des déchets ont créé des
ateliers qui permettent par exemple
comme dans le cadre de la semaine qui va
veut dire voilà de récupérer et de
réutiliser en fait les objets que nous
récupérons et donc de leur donner une
deuxième vie et des comment ça se passe
justement comment on récupère ces objets
paris soit un apport volontaire d'accord
soit nous les récupérons hop en porte à
porte chez les personnes lorsque les
objets sont volumineux puisque nous
prenons tous types d'objets y compris
des meubles et donc on peut aller à
domicile chercher ses objets ses meubles
lorsqu'ils sont trop volumineux pour que
les gens les uns portent eux-mêmes
alors on l'a dit à partir de samedi
c'est la semaine européenne de réduction
des déchets quelle importance à vos yeux
à cet événement mais écoutez c'est très
important c'est fondamental ça puisque
nous on rentre vraiment totalement dans
cette volonté de réduire les déchets je
pense que c'est une semaine qui est
importante parce que c'est ces deux-là
sens il faut faire de la sensibilisation
à la prévention des déchets aujourd'hui
je crois que les français qu'on se fasse
produit 590 kg de déchets par an ça fait
plus d'un kilo et par jour
donc c'est énorme et donc
moins de la moitié recyclés au final
voilà donc ce qui est si on peut
participer nous avec notre activité et
par le biais de cette semaine toutes les
animations qui vont avoir lieu à
sensibiliser la population au fait que
le geste prévention déchets est un geste
que chacun peut mettre en oeuvre eh bien
écoutez c'est si important pour nous en
tous les cas par rapport à notre
activité en faire changer les mentalités
vous allez vous y employer vous l'avez
dit par deux mobilisations qui se passe
dans pendant cette semaine européenne
ressources et vous propose par exemple
ce week end un atelier zéro déchet oui
c'est absolument on va faire un atelier
en fait de de réutilisation des tissus
pour fabriquer des lingettes et des
tapis de salle de bain voilà donc on va
découper des des tissus qui sont qui
nous ont été amenés en en apport
volontaire et on va les réutiliser pour
faire toutes ces petites lingettes et
ses tapis quelque chose de pédagogique
de praticiens l'absolu il a fait montre
comment on peut réutiliser pratiquement
cessé ses propres déchets un atelier ce
samedi à de 15h à 17h et donc le
week-end prochain samedi 25 et dimanche
26 novembre y aura un atelier par jour
de 15h à 17h la sterne atelier tissage
tissage riz alors là ça va être plus
artistique on va dire puisque on a une
tisserande qui va venir et qui va
montrer aux personnes qui viendront
suivre cette animation
comment avec des écheveaux de tissus
recyclés
on peut faire de la tapisserie voilà ce
sera plus créatifs et mais aussi à base
de tissus récupérés
il ya un prix d'entrée pour ces ateliers
non non non les gens peuvent
éventuellement s'il le souhaite
adhérer à l'association pour nous
soutenir et verser un montant qui leur
paraît juste pour nous aider est-ce
qu'il faut s'inscrire au préalable oui
bien sûr il faut s'inscrire au préalable
donc vous allez sur notre site et je
viens les accusations merci en bas de
l'écran merci marie fut luxe d'avoir est
avec nous merci à vous je rappelle
membre du comité de pilotage de
l'association ressourcez-vous la
ressourcerie du sud yvelines et donc
pour plus d'informations vous pouvez
vous rendre sur le site internet de
l'association
c'est ce week end à versailles
traditions et savoir faire local ont
rendez vous au palais des congrès pour
la cour des métiers d'art 70 artisans
présenteront leurs créations parmi eux
elodie schmitt créatrice de vêtements
installé dans la cité royale et de la
couture haut de gamme et nouvelle marque
de prêt-à-porter à découvrir jusqu'à
dimanche sujet signés camille lambert
[Musique]
j'ai créé deux modèles de robes pour
l'exposition de norman rockwell
donc j'ai repris les grands lignes de
ses tableaux en me basant sur les
coloris qui l'utilisaient
notamment le vert et le rouge il ya une
forme de de légèreté dans ses tableaux
un côté enfantin des robes penser comme
des oeuvres d'art inspirées par cet
adage qui dit que la mode est un éternel
recommencement
elodie schmitt crée des vêtements pour
femmes élégant et originaux c'est ici
dans son atelier boutique de versailles
qu'elle imagine et réalise elle même
robe de mariée ou tenues de cérémonie
elles ont été passionnées par la mode
les vêtements le dessin est
le travail manuel façon générale depuis
l'âge de 7 ans g
j'avais envie de créer des vêtements un
rêve devenu réalité après des études
d'arts appliqués et de costumière elodie
a lancé son entreprise de création de
vêtements sur mesure il y a trois ans
face au succès rencontré la jeune femme
de 28 ans a décidé d'élargir son offre
sa nouvelle marque
azzedine elsa l'insee est une marque de
prêt-à-porter de robes de mariée et de
tenues de mariage essentiellement mais
il y aura toujours cette partie sur
mesure et effectivement où on va créer
des pièces uniques des matières nobles
et un savoir faire qui ont un coût
minimum 500 euros pour une robe simple
pour alimenter le catalogue shooting
obligatoires cela fait un an qu'elle
collabore avec charlotte aujourd'hui
essayages de robes de mariées tuer dit
un petit peu ce que ce que j'aimais dans
ses modèles elle elle m'a conseillé sur
ce qu'il irait mieux avec mon bon profil
ma silhouette
la première impression c'est vraiment
con ce sens hyper bien dedans on n'aime
pas on n'est pas gêné on est comme dans
une robe de tous les jours des créations
qui seront présentés au public du 17 au
19 novembre lors de la cour des métiers
d'art à versailles la vente en ligne de
la marque
asa line est prévue prochainement c'est
la fin de ce set 8 journal avant de se
quitter une information vous parlais au
début de ce journal de la mobilisation
ce matin devant le tribunal de grande
instance de versailles mobilisation et
de soutien pour neuf salariés de l'usiné
psa de poissy il comparaissait en début
d'après-midi pour séquestration de leur
chef d'equipe une information qui vient
de tomber c'est le procureur de la
république un qui a requis 5 mois de
prison avec sursis pour ces neuf
salariés le délibéré du procès sera
connu le 20 décembre prochain
ce journal vous pouvez bien sûr le
retrouver en replay les reportages sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile tv 78 demain vendredi vous
retrouvez le 7-8 l'hebdo avec nicolas
kirillovitch le 7-8 journal revient
lundi pour une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]